[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dax shepherd just slayed some carpool
karaoke
yeah that checks out dax who shares two
daughters eight-year-old lincoln and
six-year-old delta with his wife kristen
bell took to instagram on tuesday to
share a sweet clip
belting out adele's hit hello with one
of his daughters during an rv trip
through the mountains
[Applause]
[Music]
the chip star captioned the video quote
heaven is a place on a twisty two-lane
mountain pass where screaming adele with
your daughter
is required
earlier this year the 46 year old actor
chatted with jimmy kimmel about
finally finding the perfect motorhome
for his family
i have been in search of a very specific
motorhome for a decade
i bet i dedicate 40 minutes a night
looking in bed at motorhomes
it's very hard to get the one i wanted
with bunk beds for the girls
and i found it jimmy dax also shared a
pic of the impressive bus
which includes bunk beds a king-sized
bed
a full kitchen a washer and dryer and
two
showers it's so fun at the time
dax said they hadn't taken any trips yet
but
it appears their family road trips have
officially kicked
off
[Applause]
[Music]
dax and kristin usually keep lincoln and
delta off of their social media accounts
hiding their faces when they do decide
to post pics with them
so this daddy daughter duet is extra
special
they're so cute as for dax and kristen
when etie caught up with the frozen star
back in 2020
she was literally everyone when she
opened up about the challenges of
quarantining with a spouse we have
gotten on each other's
last nerve this last couple weeks
it's we're doing much better now because
we're laughing about it but we were not
laughing about it for the first couple
days
and that's the hard spot and she went
into detail about why they were having
so much trouble
i love spending time with him and he
loves spending time with me but i think
what is different about this quarantine
time is you have so much more time to
think about the other person and their
actions
and sort of um replay what they said or
or
or attach a meaning to something that
they did
and like that i could do without nobody
really needs time for that that's
that's useless while quarantine may have
been momentarily tough on their marriage
lockdown life was awesome for dax
physique
in quarantine i said to kristen
i've been waiting for 10 years for
marvel to call so that i'd have an
excuse to get
huge and they're not going to call like
that ship sailed i'm 46
they're not going to call so i just have
to do it for my own amusement during a
recent episode of armchair expert
dax revealed he gained about 24 pounds
of muscle
working out six days a week i'm 185 on
the
on the button baby i've always 185 and
now i'm 210. i spent my whole life as a
medium boy and now i'm a big boy and i
like it
you